fine we'll do the freaking matrix from
the Wachowski brothers bird siblings
comes the mind-blowing sci-fi game
changer and the two signals that took a
huge steaming dump on it The Matrix and
its sequels prepare for the most
original sci-fi franchise and Star Wars
that ultimately win all Jar Jar Binks on
itself
kinda like Star Wars relive all the
awesome moments you love from the first
film the one sequence you like from the
second and absolutely nothing from the
third Jack into the matrix a virtual
reality simulation of the late 90s full
of flip phones payphones minidiscs
outfits straight out of a Marilyn Manson
video and AOL screen names this is a
punk switch and psych
tank and his big brother goes you've got
mail watch as one hacker named neo which
is an anagram for one becomes the one
who can only make one facial expression
but he's not alone meet Trinity the love
of Neos life and Morpheus the other love
of Neos life what you know you can't
explain what you feel it is the same as
brawn
you are the one leo I've spent my entire
life looking for you try to relax
this will feel than a weird here's the
one
gotcha get a room you two together
they'll face off against Agent Smith a
villain so cool they just copied him a
bunch of times instead of coming up with
another cool bad guy watch as these two
battle in this awesomely choreographed
kungfu fight then in this cgi post and
then in this Dragon Ball Z ripoff
kamehameha journey to the matrix a world
of limitless possibilities that had
audiences everywhere questioning their
own existence and then journey to Zion a
world of sweaty cave ravers really we're
gonna spend half of this trilogy here we
just watched some bullet time again nice
so settle in for a film that spawned a
thousand imitators from its effects to
its tone to its wardrobe to its own
sequels
and prepare for the thinking man's
action franchise that got stuck way too
far up its own ass but the end of part 2
while this sensor functioned it was
obviously fundamentally flawed thus
creating the otherwise contradictory
systemic anomaly that if left unchecked
might threaten the system itself
ergo those that I have no idea what he's
talking about it is it too late for me
to take the blue pill
starring kung fu Jesus female Keanu
Reeves Lawrence and the Machine white
chicks the poor achill where it all went
wrong Jaden's mom the last spoon bender
mr. ambien mormons Squidward and monica
bellucci huh just getting beers the
matrix added sequels you know it's a bad
sign when your video game and
direct-to-dvd cartoon are better than
your movies goodbye click on the Box to
the left for the screen juggie show
one-year extravaganza featuring cinemas
is how it should have ended the
nostalgia critic and many more yeah
[ __ ]
magnets better call Saul my name is a
sex reader and you can go yourself I'm
gonna send you to Belize if we're gonna
go that way you're gonna need a bigger
knife say the words say you want this
nothing happens until I hear you say it